this is deep in our calculus about what
a good experience is for a customer and
what's healthy
for the future of our industry and the
the future of the world
okay so stop me if this isn't the first
tech executive you've heard
wax on about how their product can save
the world except this isn't just
any tech executive this is apple's craig
federighi
he sits right below apple ceo tim cook
on the org chart
does tim cook really call you superman
certainly not to my face
okay does he call you air force one lord
no
usually craig the software on your
iphone ipad or mac
federighi oversees the development of it
all
he's got a lot of power and he's been
putting it behind a new privacy
feature called att app tracking
transparency
being released today in ios 14.5 apps
now have to ask to track you in a pop-up
like this
apple only gave me 15 minutes with mr
federich to talk about the new feature
joanna am i just a voice do i have a
face so
i've got my stopwatch i did not trust
the apple stopwatch app
i'm going to give you 30 seconds to
explain
what app tracking transparency is all
right i think i can do it in eight
seconds and go app tracking transparency
gives users the choice of whether they
want to be tracked across apps and
websites
8.69 oh sorry
i could do it again faster well it's a
bit deeper than that
it also affects something called the
idfa which is an identifier that ios has
had for many years
every iphone has this unique tracking
number and it's used to track your
activity between
apps so say you're thinking about buying
i don't know
craig's blue shirt in this shopping app
the shopping app has your unique
tracking number
then you open your favorite social media
app and what do you know
a shirt ad that's because the two apps
shared info
using the idfa in ios 14.5
this number isn't automatically shared
if you want to let the app share it
you'd have to tap
allow here we needed to make sure both
that the the user
had a clear understanding of the
decision and that we gave the developer
an opportunity to explain
themselves as to the purpose for which
they were potentially asking to track
and and so the developer of course can
present
messaging even before they ask the
system to
prompt the user and then they also get a
little area on the panel itself to
explain that
they're using this for presenting more
effective ads or whatever the case may
be
why the verbiage ask not to track why
not just
do not track there are other techniques
that developers over time
have developed like fingerprinting as a
bit of cat and mouse game around
other ways that an app might scheme to
create a tracking identifier and it's a
policy
issue for us to say you must not do that
and so we can't ensure the system level
that they're not tracking
we can do so at a policy level will
there be any apple apps with the att
pop-up
no not at this time i mean there's no
apple app or service
that tracks that there's no app that is
sharing information with external data
brokers no app or service of ours
that is tracking you across other
vendors apps
and websites if we ever did do something
that fits the definition of
of tracking we of course would have to
show that prompt so i wanted to read a
quote from steve jobs back in 2010 and
he said i believe
some people want to share more data than
other people do ask them
ask them every time we the people of the
internet we're sort of
sick of pop-ups i don't want to speak
for everyone on the internet but i think
most are how did you think about that i
share
your frustration with sometimes being
bombarded with
uh you know every website uh usually
telling you that they're going to track
you with a big blue accept button and no
no real choice at all we had to make it
a meaningful choice and we had to make
it a clear
choice and one that had effect and that
i think is in deep contrast to most of
what you see
on the internet as people get today's
update and
begin to launch apps they'll see it at
first and pretty soon this will become
a pretty infrequent occurrence um both
because some apps will
uh stop tracking or maybe never did
and the apps that you use that do track
you'll make that decision once and
that'll be it
you also have a choice to turn off all
these pop-ups and completely opt out of
any tracking in all
apps you can go to settings privacy
tracking
and switch off allow apps to ask to
track what will craig do
for me ask app not to track and well
that's what the industry expects the
majority of people to pick too
and all sorts of companies apps and
social media networks that rely on data
for personalized advertising
aren't happy about it facebook
specifically has called apple's mob
hypocritical and anti-competitive
we've been on this road of
improving privacy protections in our
platform for really since the beginning
of iphone and before that truthfully
and so we're we're accustomed to
initially some panicked responses from
some quarters it wasn't surprising to us
i think to hear that some people were
going to
push back on this but at the same thing
we were completely confident that it's
the right thing to give users a choice
here
but what's in all of this for apple is
this all altruistic for this trillion
dollar company
how much is privacy factoring into
buying decisions do you have a sense of
that
boy i don't know i i'd hope that it's
it's a value that is so
deep in in us personal information
can be used and abused and even
weaponized in ways that can be really
really destructive
often in a way that's not at all
apparent to the person who might be
giving up that information years ago
people were saying oh
privacy is dead no one you know they've
all everyone's given up their privacy
and so
we just kept doing it um because to us
regardless of whether it was a selling
point for a phone we thought it was the
right thing
a lot of the criticism right now about
apple is about control
and that it has too much control
specifically over its platforms and the
app store
what's the conversation like right now
amongst you and other top brass at apple
about this well i think we've always
felt that
customers have a real choice in terms of
what phone they want to buy what
ecosystem they want to be a part of
and we think we're offering people a
choice to
buy into an ecosystem where there is a
degree of curation where there is
protection for privacy where there are
certain standards
we don't think everyone's going to
prefer that choice do you feel like
there will need to be from apple
lessening of some of the control
i don't know i feel like we're making
the right choices now we're always
considering the right things
primarily from a customer perspective so
as long as we're keeping our eye
on on that north star uh i i think we
feel good about the course we're on
and of course i had to sneak in a few
non-privacy questions
wireless charging corded charging i am
primarily
a a cord guy i have enough devices that
uh
it works out for me with my my stacking
arrangements tim said
uh i believe it was a couple of weeks
ago that he says he won't be at apple
for
you know at least in the next 10 years
he will he will not stay at apple for
the next 10 years
your name's being floated insanity
yeah no that would be that would be
irresponsible how's the software going
in the mixed reality headset
i don't know anything about what you're
talking about what do you think of mixed
reality
i think it's got a lot of potential i
think it deserves exploration whatever
that next big apple product looks like
it's a pretty safe bet that mr federighi
is going to be pushing
hard for privacy in it these devices are
so
intimately a part of our lives and
contains so much
of what we're thinking and where we've
been and who we've been with that
users deserve and need control of that
information
abuses can range from creepy to
dangerous